good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson it's unhappy monday things are
changing fast as you know and you can
tell how fast they're changing by the
way that people talk about politics
language reflects feelings and thoughts
when your views change shows the way you
talk about them and that's especially
true of liberals who have very deep
feelings and their main feeling this has
always been true is contempt for you
if you ever listen to npr you know
exactly how much contempt liberals have
for you and you get to pay for it nbr
npr takes your tax dollars and then
lectures you about how immoral you are
that is liberalism distilled it's been
going on a long time npr's been running
its particular scam since 1971
but the sneering tone you hear on npr
has been the hallmark of liberals for
nearly a century
liberals have contempt for dwight
eisenhower and for barry goldwater and
for richard nixon boy did they and for
gerald ford even
if you're old enough to remember ronald
reagan you will recall vividly how
liberals felt about him
reagan was an idiot they told you a
mouth breather and so was anybody who
would vote for him very much including
you
in the words of al gore republicans were
the quote extra chromosome right wing
so they were literally genetically
defective
that's how liberals actually talk
wherever two or more liberals are
gathered you will find sanctimony
but there's a new inflection you may
have noticed it recently the pivot and
it was a pivot came six years ago it was
during the 2016 presidential campaign
liberals seem to lose any remaining
sense of humor the moment donald trump
arrived why
because he called their bluff looking
back it's obvious what happened by
2016 no one could argue that liberal
programs or many programs the various
fads and metaphorical wars we were
waging on this or that bad thing there
was no evidence that any of it had done
anything to improve american life
liberals promised you they would make
everything great but they didn't
in fact every single liberal enthusiasm
failed
from radical feminism to urban renewal
from outsourcing to the so-called
sharing economy all of them each and
every one turned out to be a complete
disaster
the reason 2016 was significant is
that's the year liberals could no longer
deny this they couldn't say give us
another 50 years and we'll turn
baltimore into geneva
they couldn't say that because no one
would believe it not even their own
voters would believe that so for
liberals 2016 was a profoundly
humiliating moment and those can be good
well-adjusted adults learn from
humiliating moments but that's not what
liberals did
they turned their rage outward and they
focused that rage on the people they had
failed
you always hate the ones you betray
so liberals decided they hated the
american middle class
in 2016 democrats stopped making
arguments in favor of their own policies
whatever those might be and instead
reoriented the entire party around
attacking the very people that
historically they had represented again
america's middle class now they hated
them
at a fundraiser she thought was off the
record hillary clinton summed up the
contempt all of them felt listen
you could put
half of trump supporters into what i
call the basket of deplorables racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic you name it
a gaffe yeah in the sense she was
telling you exactly what she really
thinks she meant every word of that and
the applause that she received was
heartfelt too they all felt that way and
that's why 2016 was the year that you
and everybody else became a racist it
was the worst slur they could think of
they used it every day of the 2016
campaign racist racist racist
well in the end and they hated this
above all donald trump won more
non-white votes than any republican
presidential candidate ever but they
didn't stop
no they just increased the volume
and by 2020 a lot of americans were just
exhausted
fine we'll vote for a mannequin if only
you will calm down
that was the unspoken yet very clear
deal that liberals made with the country
if you ditch the orange man we will stop
screaming and burning your cities and we
can be all americans again so people
voted for biden maybe not 81 million but
some people did
but democrats didn't mean it
by january of last year the democratic
party had more power than at any time
since fdr was president but the telling
point the tip-off
was they didn't seem happy about it if
anything they seemed angrier than ever
why
because they had lost faith in their own
program
they controlled everything but they had
no
interest in making things better they
were no longer interested at all in
social improvement
social security they bragged about that
for almost 100 years they stopped
talking about it head start remember
that improving public schools these were
all liberal enthusiasms they tried them
all and none of them worked so they
moved in the other direction instead of
trying to fix the country they decided
to destroy the country and just start
over
if you were watching from outside it
looked like they were having a fit
they erupted into uncontrollable
nihilistic rage they swept the plates
off the table punched a hole in the
drywall threw a vase on the tv burn it
down let's start over
they call this the equity agenda
and you should have been nervous when
you listen to him talk about it because
every time they talked about the equity
agenda they scowled
joe biden looked angry at his own
inauguration he had promised hope
but in the end he delivered division and
rage
this is biden on the day he became
president
and now
a rise of political extremism
white supremacy domestic terrorism
that we must confront and we will defeat
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal
that we're all are created equal
and the harsh
ugly reality that racism
nativism fear
demonization
have long torn us apart
the battle is perennial
huh what was that
that wasn't the deal we got rid of the
orange man and you're still calling me
racist why are you doing that why aren't
you trying to unite the country why
don't you win over the people who didn't
vote for you
they didn't spend one day doing that
instead they moved in the opposite
direction at high speed
they all of a sudden declared that
trespassing was a felony and through
trump voters in prison a lot of them are
still there
they said about politicizing the most
heavily armed federal agencies from the
fbi to dhs to the pentagon that should
make you nervous
and they did it for a reason because
they believed their political opponents
were criminals and you know that because
they said so they called them nazis and
white supremacists you
you're not a nazi or white supremacist
why are they calling you that
why are they denouncing you as a
seditionist an enemy of the state why
are they demanding that governments
censor and disarm you because they think
you're a terrorist
they deployed thousands of national
guard troops to your capital and kept
them there for months what against
americans we weren't being invaded those
were trump voters they claimed to be
afraid of
they began using language that even the
most radical democrat in congress just
six years ago would have thought was way
too extreme
and it wasn't just a few of them who did
this virtually all of them did it
certain dates echo throughout history
december 7 1941
september 11
2001. and january sixth
twenty twenty one similar to pearl
harbor and uh nine eleven
we can now add january sixth twenty
twenty one
to that very short list of dates in
american history
that will live
forever in infamy the worst attack on
our democracy since the civil war the
worst attack on our democracy since the
civil war and this was the worst attack
on our democracy since
the civil war the worst single act of
political violence since the civil war
the worst attack on american democracy
arguably probably since the civil war
the 1-6 attacks are likely to kill a lot
more americans that were killed on the 9
11 attacks january 6 was worse than 9
11.
why are they talking like that it's so
obviously untrue and yet they're all
reading from the same script there has
to be a purpose here they're not doing
this accidentally people don't use
identical chunks of language on the same
day
by accident they thought this through
and then they began putting people on
television whose only qualification
was their willingness to say things that
again three years ago would have been
considered beyond the pale
and that's just a few of them a lot of
them here's a former trump
administration lackey telling you the
straight face that the republican party
is a bigger threat to this nation than
al qaeda or isis radicalized elements of
the republican party now represent a
bigger threat to our democracy than
organizations like al qaeda or isis ever
did now not necessarily to human lives
not necessarily but a bigger threat to
our democracy than those terrorist
groups ever did
so why are they talking this way what
else are they going to talk about
their record in detroit for the last 60
years no
the democratic party decided the only
way it could maintain power when the
next election is to convince you the
voter that the other side
is dangerous literally dangerous not
metaphorically dangerous actually
dangerous to your life
the problem is you have to up the ante
in every election
if they're white supremacists this
election what are they next election
nazis and then what
john brennan the former cia director
said he looked forward to an
authoritarian crackdown
you'll notice he lumps in libertarians
with fascist bigots and racists watch
this
looking forward that the members of the
the biden team who have been nominated
or have been appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements that we've seen overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians fascists bigots
racists nativists
even libertarians
that was the month that joe biden was
inaugurated the month you'd think
liberals like john brennan would be
celebrating trump's departure but again
they were angrier than ever and they've
gotten angrier since that day so where's
this going well it's going the only
place it ever could go
democrats have reached the logical end
of name calling why because they've run
out of epithets once you've accused your
political opponents of being nazis white
supremacists and then of treason you
have reached the limits of language when
you're dealing with someone who's
committed treason it is now a law
enforcement matter people are going to
have to be physically punished
so not surprisingly that is what they
are now calling for arrest them
all of a sudden you're hearing a lot of
liberals say that
not just the crazies but the mainstream
people willard mitt romney a man who's
probably never used the f word as in in
his entire life is suddenly accusing
congresswoman tulsi gabbard of hawaii
one of the most reasonable people ever
to serve in the body
of treason
not accusing her of being mistaken or
wrong but accusing her of betraying her
country even as she serves it in uniform
what's the penalty for that
well it's prison at least
watch
tulsi gabbard is being accused of
spreading russian false flag propaganda
and i think doj in the same way that it
is setting up a task force to
investigate oligarchs should look into
people who are russian propagandists and
shilling for putin they used to arrest
people for doing stuff like this if they
thought you were
colluding with a russian agent if they
thought you were putting out information
or taking information and handing over
to russia they used to actually
investigate stuff like this and i guess
now you know there seems to be no bars
yeah it's the view they're harpies
they're ridiculous they're stupid all
true
but what was so surprising is that that
wasn't even considered much of a news
story it's that common
a liberal fundraising group called call
to action is now demanding the arrest of
clarence thomas's wife jenny thomas
someone who as far as we know hasn't
done anything wrong apart from marrying
a man that liberals don't like
so even five years ago if some liberal
group was raising money on the idea
ginny thomas should be arrested because
she's married to clarence thomas that
would have seemed demented now it's just
another cable news segment a lot of them
are like that here's former fox reporter
carl cameron on cnn this weekend calling
for us this show to be sent to prison
because that's now the fair penalty for
disagreeing with joe biden jail time
and the host of the show on cnn seems to
think that sounds about right
in this particular case
tucker has been screaming fire in a
crowded movie house for years and that
cliche
really comes to the matter of what is
free speech
and the fact of the matter is if you
disturb the peace by starting orion in a
movie theater cops are going to arrest
you and you might end up in jail or you
might end up in something
and that kind of stuff absolutely has to
stop
uh whether it's the anti-trust bill to
take down and de-platform people who lie
and put out falsehoods that cause damage
and violent violent hate
uh
there ought to be something done about
it and the
the administration is beginning to
actually make a move on that and it's
been way overdue
administration is beginning to make a
move on that says the journalist
maybe wind up in jail or maybe something
worse quote well what's something worse
we're not sure what something worse is
but it certainly feels like we're moving
toward it at very high speed at this
point that's the end point to talk like
that something worse
because rhetoric has its own internal
logic you've experienced it you can talk
yourself into things we've all done that
democrats are doing it right now
and what they're talking themselves into
right now is quote something worse it's
scary
it is time to pull back
it is time to de-escalate
otherwise this is going to get really
ugly really soon
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight